I'm not cross okay,
but I'm excited.
But I am married to a woman I have known for 20 years.
We have 2 children together.
Alright,
now I get it.
If you know each other for 20 years,
you are of course no longer queer.
FROM the 2.
Decade automatically turns to heterosexualities.
But seriously,
how Alice Weidel defines herself is her business.
And if it does not want to use the term queer for itself,
it is also absolutely legitimate.
What I find difficult,
though,
is that she plays gay and queer against each other.
Their own homosexuality and queer family is okay,
but transright ones for example go way too far.
I actually feel more excited in front of the carts um by an absolutely,
how shall I say,
almost stupid genderpolitik.
The point is simple,
Alice Weidel's "normal" homosexual family is also an enemy image for the AfD.
I do not feel discriminated against.
Why should I?
The party's basic program is that homosexual parents destroy the traditional
image of the family and are at most a pseudo family.
Alice Weides' strategy of presenting herself as OB - she is simply a heteronormative
person who happens to be married to a woman - will
therefore not work in the long run,
because the party she represents vehemently rejects that as well.
The 2 common children she has with her wife are therefore not the common
children and their family ne pseudo family for her own party.
OB she will understand that someday?
It remains exciting.